quelques heures de route suffisent pour
s'enfoncer dans une afrique de carte
postale celle qui fait tant rêver
steve connaît la région comme sa poche
c'est ici qu'il est né et a grandi juste
en bordure du masaï mara la réserve la
plus visitée par les touristes
[Musique]
tout le monde veut venir un masaï mara a
causé sa faune incroyables
notamment la fameuse migration des
animaux ils se déroulent ici nulle part
ailleurs on peut trouver autant de bêtes
sauvages
chaque jour 200 mini bus amène ici 700
touristes presser le pas
mais avant d'entrer dans le parc et de
payer un supplément de 60 $ par personne
des masaï s'avance vers nous et la
rencontre va être plutôt hachée
au début elle arrive à 2 mais très vite
d'autres les rejoignent les bras chargés
de babylone elle se lance dans une vente
agressive et déterminée habitué aux
touristes elles savent dire les prix
dans toutes les langues y compris en
français
[Musique]
tout à un prix ici même les photos qui
coûte entre 200 et 400 shillings kényans
soit près de quatre heures
les masaï ont compris que les étrangers
ont les poches pleines de dollars
et cette bonne guerre pour un peuple qui
vit dans une extrême pauvreté
notre voiture parvient à s'échapper la
horde de vendeuse va se jeter sur les
autres 4 4 qui arrive juste derrière
[Musique]
à peine la grille franchie steve croise
un autre guide il s'agit d'une vieille
connaissance et aujourd'hui il a de
bonnes nouvelles à lui annoncé
j'avais vu quelque chose
auquel j b alors
visiblement nous ne sommes pas les seuls
à avoir été mis au courant tout comme
nous un flot de 4,4 fonce dans la même
direction
il faut faire vite avant que l'animal ne
s'échappe car les léopards sont
extrêmement rares il peut se passer des
mois sans en voir un seul
steve accélère sur la route boueuse il
faut quitter la piste pour s'enfoncer
dans la savane nous sommes secoués
jusqu'à un virage où attendent en file
indienne une bonne vingtaine de
véhicules
nous sommes bloqués comme dans un
embouteillage en plein centre-ville
[Musique]
c'était vraiment un gros trafic on est
en plein embouteillage
de voiture et je ne peux pas passer sur
le côté pour me rapprocher de l'arbre
car je j'aimerais les touristes qui
veulent prendre des photos il faut donc
que j'attends de mon tour pour presser
repartir à cannes d'après ce que je vois
je pense qu'il ya au moins 25 voitures
25 voitures juste pour ce léopard qui se
cache dans l'arbre
c'est à peine si on distingue son pelage
en tout cas ce n'est pas assez pour les
touristes qui ont sorti leurs appareils
photos il faut donc se rapprocher un peu
plus de l'animal
un 4 4 sort de la file et décide de se
placer juste au pied de l'arbre
immédiatement d'autres limites et
bientôt tous en cercle léopard
même des enfants sont là à quelques
centimètres du faux d'un simple bon la
bête peut à tout moment ce jeudi je suis
heureuse mais cela ils n'en ont pas
conscience
c'est la première fois que vous venez
ici ouais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est incroyable
vous êtes d'où espagne madrid et ça ne
vous gêne pas de voir tous ces voitures
comme ça au même endroit il y en a pas
assez
vous voyez sortir de la route comme nous
l'avons fait c'est interdit
d'une part on dérange des animaux et en
plus on abîme la végétation avec nos
voitures
pour
ça nous veiller de on peut être bannis
du parc pour deux ans bien photo ou
avoir une amende revue offline en
despote
pour satisfaire leurs clients
les guides se met en infraction avec la
loi kényane
mais crise économique oblige les
touristes se font rares et pas question
de les mécontenter
pour les premiers arrivés la séance
photo se termine ils laissent leur place
à de nouveaux arrivants qui laboure un
peu plus le chemin jusqu'à le rendre
impraticable
s'embourber c'est l'une des angoisses
majeur du guide
car ici il ne fait pas bon rester de
nuit quand les prédateurs prennent le
contrôle du parquet
ce mini vans a pris un virage un peu
trop large et se retrouve coincé
il donne des conseils aux chauffeurs qui
commence à peiner il faut faire vite car
dans une demi heure ce sera la nuit
[Musique]
à la crainte en poupe
joli
comme ça
tout se termine bien le tourisme de
masse peut continuer à masaï mara
[Musique]